helmut newton jeudi que vous étiez un
photographe de mode mais il semble vous
êtes plus que cinq ans photographe de
mon père je suis redevenu de plus tôt
j'ai passé trois jours trois jours ou a
plutôt à bon ok ce que vous avez vu tous
les faits damade wiki 13 élégante redit
dans quel cadre
les tours de ayo se sont ajoutés à ces
services je me fascine il est lui très
longtemps c'est la douzième fois je
reviens là leurs noms dont douze mois
pour photographier la mode mais en
général vous savez c'est quand j'ai dit
je suis élevé dont avec dans une grande
ville et pour moi faire mon métier mes
photos j'ai besoin du thé des grandes
villes d'abord les raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai mis à paris ça c'est la
ville que m'allume le plus là où je peux
faire vraiment trop disent les victimes
un nul mais j'aime manu c'est une vie
c'est comme une femme je suis un
photographe de femmes et jeux photos
doivent faire que jamais des hommes ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup
le ville ce trait comme une femme les
après la première fois je suis arrivé à
paris
c'était en 1957 j'ai pris j'étais avec
ma femme on n'a pas connu de la route
j'ai pris un taxi pour que les taxis
montrent le chemin et suis arrivée
boulevard raspail ya bien deux hôtels où
je réserve une chambre j'ai pris un
verre sur une terrasse de café et j'ai
dit à ma femme on va rester ici pour
pour très très longtemps on a fait
c'était 20 créateurs
c'était c'était qu'on dit le coup de
foudre
j'ai aussi eu un coup de foudre peu
utile par exemple de new york
j'aime beaucoup moins que carl et mais
messi avait plus de femmes dans ses
villes ses villages où les femmes ah oui
il faudrait enfin je peux pas faire
d'eux des photos de l'architecturé je
m'intéresse pas beaucoup et architecture
avec une femme où ça marche très bien
bon on va voir donc des photographies
signées helmut newton extraites de votre
album nuits blanches zi
filipacchi de noël et ce sont des est-ce
qu'on peut dire de vos photographies
qu'elles sont sophistiqués je crois ce
que je peux dire on peut dire qu'elles
soient spécifiques ce qu'est ce qu'il
fait là dame mensuel ma pire écrit on a
beau jeu qui lui arrache une dent fin du
que vous n'avez pas bien regardé mais ça
sont des photographies mais ce qui vous
intéresse le plus c'est le corps de la
femme ou bien au dessous or quand les
vêtements sont pas du tout important
mais alors qu'est-ce que la tête avait
attaché la d1 du tout elle ferme damas
vous voyez bien ça s'appelle sécurité
new york effets de larsen face à balla
et vous voyez aller sur un lit avec un
sel sur le dos voilà paloma picasso avec
le machin mart
ce sont deux dames où il y avait une
annonce à saint jude est rarement hélas
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas davantage un
metteur en scène qu'un photographe
pas du tout je suis j'ai fait une mise
en scène mais il ya toujours une base de
vérité parce que bon vous avez vu les
deux filles qui s'embrassent quand le
studio ça peut se passer il ya toujours
il ya des fautes au delà du foot que
vous avez demandé si elle rassure un
temps n'arrache pas dedans il m'a fait
la dame tout nu qui m'a qui va si on
maquille avant l'émission ici j'ai
jamais vu non mais ça c'est ça c'est
basé sur madame claude
j'ai fait on m'a demandé à faire ma
version du film de d'équité faire sur la
vie de madame claude et moi j'ai jamais
vu le film j'ai fait ma version parce
que je suis passionné par le sujet et ça
fait partie de cette vérité mais sont
vos fantasmes nous fait passer dans
photographie tout le monde la fontasse
je suis sur ce centre a des fantasmes
sûrement nous moi moi j'étais fonds
caserne vôtre
alors c'est pas vous vous l'êtes pas me
dire jeter sur moi je suis peut-être
plus france que vous c'est vrai il est
très très sensible supputations
c'est de vous tous plus franc travers
ses photographies non il est il est de
plus subjectif peut-être parce que c'est
le ces sommes le seul photographe qui
fait vraiment de mise en scène je ne dis
pas qu'il est à mettre enceinte je crois
qu'elles ont le droit de refuser ce
titre les photographes mais mais il fait
la mise en scène et je crois que tous
les autres photographes et s'ils ne
feront pas d'abord la mise en scène et
non pas d'abord de tient à trop c'est
d'abord un espace de théâtre filmé mais
vous avez été photographe de mode et je
me disais c'est une assez comique et oui
oui ça vous vous faisiez ce genre de
photos n'ont pas tout à fait jeter
monsieur vous me suis jeté le monde
c'était je crois c'est pas les photos ça
d'attendre c'était très bien non je
devenu très bien les bains non mais si
vous êtes entendre que je crois
d'ailleurs de vote cette terrible
terrible me souviens venu je me suis
fait griffer pour un type bien noises
aux bascules et à photographier c'est un
homme jeune homme de 50 ans qui a
trépigné a bien noise ou qu'ont toujours
pas bhl qu'on apprend le cas présent les
femmes sont beaucoup plus gentil va
savoir c'était un homme une femme toison
mais obama nous qu'est ce que vous
pensez des photographies d'helmut newton
je m'intéresse absolument aux antipodes
de ce que je peux faire mais c'est un
espèce de rêve étrange qui m'intéressait
je suis pas choqué du tout et en plus
libération il fait pas il fait un nom
comme ça vous savez pas c'est toujours
la réaction de toujours bandage
quand je suis a invité à un dîner de
chez les gens chez les gens pour joie
parce que tous mes amis sont pas
bourgeois - si le seul bourgeois parmi
mes amis
il ya eu dernièrement il y avait une
dame à côté de moi est très très chic et
une divorcée sur mon argent est dit que
vous appelez comment j'ai dit je
m'appelle newton départ photographe je
dis oui je suis le photographe dit mais
vous avez pas le sens qui vous coups des
deux côtés de la bouche
il n'y a pas des chaînes autour de votre
taille
les chansons sont des arbres naïm et les
femmes les femmes comme cette femme
sophistiquée comme vous mais il ya aussi
des femmes que je ressens que vos photos
grâce au très misogyne et moi ça c'est
des traits des saisons très déplaisant
mais j'ai jamais oui je peux pas me
parle pas de l'homme et l'oeuvre
l'oeuvre défini j'ai jamais pensé que
l'homme va rassembler leurs c'est plutôt
le contraire je crois c'est en se vidant
l'oeuvre on a le droit de rester très
très gentil déjà je n'entends jamais je
n'attend jamais trouvé quelqu'un
crédible ce qui fait surtout quand il
c'est une question d'aider des fantasmes
des choses en afrique
moi j'adore la fin y'a rien que j'aime
plus là on va demander d'ajouter des
amis jean dit ça ça m'a pris je vous
jure
non je n'accepte pas ça comme une vérité
une vérité objective le bon le mettre là
dans son esclave
le bourreau adore sont victimes victimes
non il ya un élément des hommes misogyne
qui disent qu'ils adorent les femmes
aimantes les femmes dans les images
humiliantes sa provence claude nori sont
pas une humiliante claude nori réécrite